folks joe derosa here guess who's back
on the road officially the run
has almost
begun
i don't have a name for this run yet of
shows quite frankly i don't like what
people name their that doesn't matter
listen here's where i'm headed july 9th
fairfield connecticut july 14th through
16th san francisco california july or
sorry august 12th through 13th atlantic
city new jersey september 1st through
3rd san diego california september 12th
somerville massachusetts and then dates
to follow in wilmington holland michigan
grand rapids michigan man i'm back out
there
go to joey
go to jotaro
fudge
go to rosa info.com go to
joederosainfo.com
and you can get your tickets there for
most of the gigs and the ones that
aren't there yet will be there very soon
that's
joederosainfo.com for tickets also while
you are in new york city
you see it here we're in the rv at joey
roses come to joey rose's
in nyc the sandwich shop and bar for all
your sandwich and alcohol needs 174
rivington street we're open tuesday
through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com for details thank you
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds hey taste
buddies welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buds and today we got a special guest
what's up what's up it is you do make it
fun that was very fun i want to shout
out to uh my buddy john augustine the
golfer
uh he's uh uh just turned pro golfer i
met him yeah he made a mature yeah giant
fan of you guys john fan of this podcast
watches this podcast all the time a
little more derozan than sal but oh
interesting well yeah he didn't really
make note of that when i saw him in
person well what's he gonna say he could
shoot me straight i mean he just i mean
his first thing would have been like hey
where's derosa yeah yeah yeah so does he
like derozamore in general or on the
podcast he sides with derozan well he
hasn't met the weight of full derozan in
person yeah but
it's he's it's the he's choosing deroza
it's the two just just just on podcast
alone entertainment purely
so go ahead
it's that's just uh
you know i'll take the compliment
no offense i think you are the
stronger entertainer here because you
fly off the handle with no reserve or
regard that's what it is yeah and i'm
more based in some sound judgments i'm
an artist i'm an artist
and you're the you're the wild card i'm
the jack i'm the constant on the jackson
pollock of this podcast and i wear it
proud i mean i'm not going to apologize
for my passion you should make a
painting with just food just throwing it
on a on a canvas and sell it your own
you'll be your own jackets i'm steps
away from it yeah i'm steps away from it
you know i mean it's i i could see
myself doing something like that very
soon i could see it and very seriously
bespoke
speaking of bespoke try check out
bespoke post but you should sell bespoke
paintings out of the bar here
where are we wait why would they be oh
oh yeah geez
we're inside okay so we build an rv
outside of joey rose's we are in the rv
at joey roses we are outside of the bar
this is our outdoor space i like it uh
it's a pretty fun place it's it's fun
and old school and retro and kitschy and
whatever and and it matches the theme
and the vibes of the bar
uh so we're in the joey rose's rv you
built essentially a home
on the street it's what it's well
probably gonna need it at some point
yeah but this is no there's tile there's
carpet there's lighting there's heating
fans electricity yeah the carpet's on
the wrong part but
yeah carpets on the ceiling yeah could
you imagine if that carver was on the
floor with that it would look no it
would be crazy yeah it'd be crazy um
going to a house from like the 70s or
80s or maybe back then you went to an
aunt's house or a grandparent's house
and they had this thick shed carpeting
yeah but it had been around already for
10 20 plus years yeah that thick layer
of dust that must be in there the
disgusting kind of thing and as kids you
rolled around it and you played it wait
do you don't think she's vacuuming the
air i don't think i think with a shared
carpet i don't think vacuuming matters
i think grandparents that's what they
live for is vacuuming yeah
i
carpet's like almost is a good idea in
theory
like it's all like when you see it
you're like it's like the first the
beginning you're like man this is nice
uh i mean probably hardwood floors but i
mean i would prefer this i'd want this
i'd want the carpet bedroom hardwood
floors area rug or wall-to-wall carpet
uh well i'm trying to think well we have
we have carpet i prefer carpet yeah i
think it's in your bedroom it's
definitely cozier but uh well i got to
tell you i got hardwood all through the
apartment and it does
i guess
serve it is a bit easier to maintain of
course because you can spot everything
immediately but that also makes it a
pain in the ass because every little
thing i mean you dr you get a drip of
soda on it
you see it whereas the carpet would just
absorb that coca-cola for decades i mean
i'm not saying gross but i'm saying
you're you're you're dripping and and
dipping and all kinds of tripping
on the carpet and not even knowing
you're doing it and never noticing on
that hardwood every single crumb that
ever falls you're like ugh okay it never
stops yeah roomba
yeah i don't have no maybe i should get
one i got my mom it's like a dog that's
a vacuum
you just let it go yeah all day long you
just let it go but the problem with new
york is a lot of baseboard radiators
and that room being that room ain't
getting underneath them you don't think
the people yeah you've been on the
website maybe they offer a product uh
please that's to consider you think
you've got something going under your
baseboards are around the world and
roomba is a product that's made to
vacuum so i feel like they have to have
spoken about what's the other problem
with the new york apartment everything
you have on your floor meaning furniture
has things underneath it because you
have no space right so that room
is going to be ricocheting all over the
place there's not much of a roomba could
do anything there's no room for the
roomba you get home the room is just
sitting on the couch smoking a cigarette
and he's like what do you want me to do
dude
there's a zoo in here
he's like this area here i vacuumed 15
times yeah because i don't know where
i'm going
it's a scene right yeah what kind of
layout is this what was it like
the sink is in the bedroom
i don't know i'm discombobulated they
didn't program me for this yeah the
roomba forms she becomes like willie
lowman and death of a salesman
you don't throw a man away yeah
you're bad at a job with a purpose
where's your bathroom at you got to use
the coffee shop downstairs that doesn't
make sense
oh it's so funny a walk up
yeah
uh yeah but but but
so we're at joey rose's but i said i did
say
why did i say it was
steps away from jacksonville i think
you're just it's just your turn
oh i think because it's because i
continue
to bring unstable professions into my
life the latest being a bar it's now a
job so i wouldn't be surprised if i
ventured into painting soon
i could see it
i could see it you're gonna be walking
the streets talking to yourself but you
would be very passionate about it that
we would all get on board
like you're very that's what you do is
you you end you enter it into your life
and then our life and then we're like
yeah dude joe is doing
like he does he paints now like it's
pretty good dude it's pretty good like
and we would just be fine with it at
first we're not but you we get beat down
to the point where we accept it yeah we
have yes we have we have group texted
before and i think in a group text with
you guys i would scream at you about how
painting is what we all need to be doing
and because the comedy scene is changing
and maybe convince you guys
the art world is much better than the
comedy scene over the pandemic i got in
my head that i should paint as a form of
therapy and just
just to calm me down i ordered like a
lot of money worth of painting products
yeah i ordered like like like 500 colors
of acrylic paint all these blank
canvases all different types of brushes
the easel yeah everything like that i
painted uh i painted twice
both times i loved it but i have all
that stuff that i have to give away so
hey i got i got the full setup i did i
do the same thing i'm not kidding
i hobby paint i'm not kidding
i'm not kidding
where can i see something you've done
remember when i said my roomba couldn't
go under anything yeah under half of my
couches all my painting supplies yeah
that's part of the reason that rumor
kicks that's your that's your treadmill
that's like the other half is my weights
that i don't yeah i swear to god
um but no i was about to ask you what i
haven't heard that you hobby paint but i
guess did you hear that i hobby painted
it no do you hobby paint no i told you i
started doing it when i lived in l.a
okay and i i don't do i won't do it for
much and then i'll break it out and do
it for a while it's incredibly relaxing
what do you do legos legos are pretty
relaxing i do do like i do legos with my
daughter and then you're like this is
fun yeah you can get lost in it and then
just it's it's very like it's one of
those things that like like painting or
swimming or watching a fish tank that
really settles me
i found like those are all three uh
things but they all do the same thing
for me you watch your fishing tank your
fish tank fish tank they say you're
watching a fish tank or like a fire you
just watch the fish tank
oh yeah see what's going on you know
like an aquarium almost yeah yeah i get
the aquarium but i get home like you
just have a little one why do you
suspect people have fish tanks uh i
don't think they were watching it like
that much you know i don't turn it on
like appointment television but like i'm
saying nine o'clock
let's see what these three missions are
samantha what are you doing back there
it's sweep squeak samantha's gonna pick
a fight with david yeah i built a i
built a little lego thing because we
have a shelf above the bar of like
action figures and stuff like that and i
bought a little gi joe lego lego thing
and i put it together i i gotta say i
found it a bit
uh it was frustrating a little bit
because you they're you are exclusively
frustrated that's why i you're not a you
don't need instructions and like they're
you don't need this system telling you
how to do this right that's why painting
would be great for you because it's like
there is no system you can do whatever
you want legos is like who's the
government telling me this you know you
feel
you don't want that and so i legos what
i could see being hard it was i didn't
like that you define the specific piece
yeah and it was hard to tell it's hard
the instructions are kind of hard so i
could watch you put a lego set together
i mean that watch it that's a website
that's a web series right there to watch
watch joe there's like a new there's
like a new one like the titanic or they
have like the millennium falcon there's
eight thousand pieces that's crazy uh
why are you putting that together you'd
go you you'd cut your off and snap
before you got to the first phase uh so
just just just to double back
you don't like the part that you don't
like about the legos is the
literal point in crux of the entire lego
project which is
looking up the pieces and putting them
together i find it a little confusing
because some of the pieces look so
similar to others
and then i don't know the last thing we
do that's part of the it's almost like a
3d jigsaw yes i i did realize that when
i did that one it was a small one i was
like oh
there's like an achievement to this like
it is supposed to be a little
challenging yeah but like i didn't
remember this from when i was a kid
the the arrows like the transparent
arrows
where they're trying to show you like a
part that's already built what goes
under it i found that
very hard to understand you know take
some practice to decipher there yeah set
up this i'll tell you what i did so q
got me as a as a gesture he got me a
fast and furious dominic toretto's dodge
charger okay he dropped it off my house
in the middle of pandemic he's like try
this i don't know it might be fun and i
that was the first lego i ever had and
it did you know there's levels there's
all different categories and levels this
one was called technics because a lot of
the parts actually worked the engine the
wheels the trunks all that stuff so i
put that together as 1100 pieces it was
fun it was fun and then i said oh this
might be my thing now
and then legos now is exploding they
have such cool [ __ ] yeah so i started
doing this thing where i'm like oh i
need that lego set so i bought the
seinfeld apartment i bought the
ghostbusters ecto one i bought um
uh
like three or four other ones like i
forget like stranger things just [ __ ]
like that and i haven't done a single
one of them so i have them all in a box
i bought oh i bought the uh uh back to
the future the delorean so i i have them
all in a box and they're just in my
closet and i don't open it and have it
start handing them over i'll start a web
series you know they go up in value you
should do
for you
the back of the restaurant you should
just be putting a lego set together and
that's part of what experience is going
to your restaurant is what do you do we
get a sandwich you go watch joe did he
lose his mind yeah we don't care that
there's no seats there's no seats cause
he took them up with yeah he's putting
together 8 000 piece lego set
uh
little hole in like the brick area you
know what like the joey rose's sign is
where you have like the
atari tapes in the wall yeah i think you
do some weird [ __ ] like like you're like
a like an elf or something like like i'm
inside that wall yeah you drill a hole
in the wall it's like more like a creepy
and people peek in and they just see you
like through the wall like in like a
dark cobbler you're like a cobbler yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're crying you're up
against the wall just bawling just good
that's very creepy that's very creepy
no the appearance of the wants
but he but but first of all i will take
the painting supplies off your hands
first of all let me start with that
second of all nate that was incredibly
insightful
when you said that the reason i didn't
like legos was the systematic approach
to the legos and that the p they're very
insightful i never knew you to be
that sharp and insightful so again and
the years have served you very well yeah
i'm just waiting to be asked you were
you were a lot more brash back in the
day
[Laughter]
uh
what kind of kind of iced tea did you
get it's a green tea is it hibiscus i
don't know that shit's hibiscus it's
like lavender
it's it tastes it literally tastes like
i'm drinking perfume and i don't want to
look a gift toss right in the eyes
but i thought i was having an on a
plumber take a sip of that i swear i had
my own you got the same tea as me yeah
what is that perfume i will admit there
was a fruitiness to it i wasn't
expecting it's fruity it's floral there
was a floralness to it i wasn't
expecting all right i swear to god it
feels like i'm drinking a [ __ ]
botanical i the guy said to me what kind
of green tea do you want i said just
give me the kind of just tastes regular
and i feel like it went in one ear and
out the other it's still a refreshing
drink though it feels like i'm drinking
sephora so do you not like it
i don't
it's okay set the guy up with an arnold
palmer who does that i do that he comes
in he's he's in a huff because he was
like got caught in some traffic i go
buddy not only do i get a bacon egg and
cheese way for you i set you with an
arnold palmer a station a set up a cup
a cup of iced tea and then a for a cold
lemonade so he can make his own yeah i'm
not complaining i actually gave you so
much praise i said i think you this
shows you that was off camp it was off
camera all right but you don't want to
all we're getting on camera is is the
hibiscus complaint yeah
uh nate we're happy to have you here
today i mean i'm excited i'm excited
nate dawg nate is here playing the
beacon theater two shows tonight yes at
7 and 9 45. if you have a time machine
go check them out yes yes nate also both
yeah
i think so and it's close dude can we do
anything for that we'll tweet about it
yeah just just push it out i go i'll be
honest there's no one in that second
show
[Laughter]
i always like tell people you go to some
city where it's like
you're off dude you're not now this is
these are both good these are both okay
i don't think they're exactly sold out
but all very very close
and then no because i was too nervous
but they did uh when you go to some town
and they're like oh maybe i'll get some
people i was like yeah dude i would love
it i'll you know bring about a thousand
people would be great
when you need them you're in just some
town you've never heard of you're like i
need everybody we were somewhere
recently and it was like we thought it
was a disappointing cell it was you with
me and it was like half full the theater
and then i found out how how many people
the town had it had in it and it was the
amount of people that were there and i'm
like this is really like why do you have
a theater this size yeah i don't
remember that i don't know if i was with
you on that or not that's very funny
though
they need everybody if you got a great
show tonight and we need all of you to
come
the town came and we're 50 sold that's
all you can ask for yeah you can all you
can ask for for the whole town to show
up how cute did the taste bud socks look
on you taste buds merch thanks yeah you
look nice in the shirt thank you thank
you so much nate uh
nate i don't mean to come at you as soon
as you get here but
it's 82 degrees outside nate is wearing
a vinyl windbreaker of some sort with a
hood i feel pipped up
i know yeah it's funny i was trying to
picture you in just a t-shirt today and
i couldn't do it and i was yeah i bet
he's gonna have a jacket on you don't do
that i have a t-shirt fashion in the way
you look now you look at you look at the
phases of nate like
the last 20 years right yeah you look at
you every like four years so look at you
five times over 20 years and
you look like a different human being
right now yeah you really came into your
own yeah i change a lot i like change
your jacket i mean it's a little warm it
doesn't feel terrible in here though uh
i'm very always cold when you wake up
obviously you know i woke up like 11
and so it's i'm all i'm very i'm a very
cold person when i wake up so it takes
me a minute to get okay uh kind of
warmed up all right i could i could wear
a t-shirt right now but i've i was
trying to think if i'd ever seen you in
just the tv i like
it's about seeing my nipples through my
shirt it's like that kind of stuff so
i've just gotten so used to like you
just want to wear something like this i
know yeah it sucks i know that was one
of your old jokes the
uh skinny face skinny fat
that's my that's why it was my first
good opener was that bit yeah tell us a
bit
i don't want to i don't comedian tell me
a joke
use this in your act
you should come down to where i work
you'll get material you know you should
do jokes on t-shirts and skinny fat yeah
i get a text from my mom now once
a month
suggesting no no not suggesting from her
where they live in a 55 and over
community once a month
do you know
johnny
beglipsi and i'm like who and she's like
we just saw him perform
at the clubhouse he is hilarious i'm
always like
i don't know who that is yeah
he's a great name
follow johnny lipstick at johnny
valencia on twitter.com yeah it's the
guy you sound like you're like i think i
opened for him a couple times like he's
been headlining for 50 years like you're
like everybody's open for him it's bound
to be i mean at some point it's there's
bound to be somebody performing there
where i'm gonna finally be like i do
and he was an [ __ ] to me yeah
at rascals in 2001 or whatever you know
you're going to show up and bury them
you just you're going to show up and
bury them and ask for a guest spot i
would i can't you're going to go in like
they're like why do you hear what are
you thinking guess what my parents live
here so i think i have the right i can't
think of a situation that bomb worship
like you know folks i'm not saying i'd
kill myself but i am saying i i if you
wanted me to die you know i mean the bad
part is i would probably i would murder
there like that's like you give me some
nice old old people i'm going to
slaughter dude
[Laughter]
i don't know i didn't always say i
always told people i'm a
comic's parents comic like every
comic's parents are like hey my parents
are going to come to your show this
weekend like you're clean and easy to
watch so they won't
oh boy it's so tough finding a credit
card here on the computer geez oh man
folks
you caught me in the middle of a credit
card search
and i want to talk to you about credit
karma do you want a new credit card but
you're not sure how to choose you don't
need to apply for the offer that you see
in the mail okay you don't need to do
that anymore you don't need to search
the internet like i'm doing right now
credit karma will help you zero in on
the right option for you so you can
apply with more confidence okay have you
ever been rejected by a credit card
i just was it happens way too often
that's why credit karma created karma
confidence technology helping our
members their members really you know i
shouldn't say our members i'm not part
of the team but i feel like maybe i am
in a spiritual sense helping the members
apply again with more confidence
earn the credit card reward you deserve
by the way you should be earning rewards
if you're using a credit card credit
karma can help you compare reward
options so you can find the card that
fits your lifestyle best and earn miles
or points or cash back whatever the heck
it is all right folks credit karma uses
your credit profile to show you offers
that are tailored to your financial
situation and your lifestyle it is that
simple they're going to get you in the
right place at the right time applying
for the right card so if you're ready to
find the card for you head to credit
karma and check out your personalized
mix of offers that are ready waiting for
you today go to creditkarma.com
or the credit karma app to find the card
for you that's creditkarma.com
so let's talk hellofresh what's
hellofresh doing hellofresh is
delivering fresh quality produce from
the farm to your door in less than a
week so you can savor those summer
flavors right from your home hellofresh
now has 30 dinner recipes to choose from
every single week for god's sakes that's
more choices than uh you're finding in
most places i got to tell you that much
it's the most choices out of any meal
kit service and that's just the facts i
like hello fresh in these summer months
things get tiring things get busy the
heat kind of wears you out sometimes
maybe you don't feel like cooking you
don't feel like going to the grocery
store or maybe you're just plain old
want to spend more time outside and
running around
after those work hours and hello fresh
is going to help you do that by again
delivering you the quality meal kits
right to your door and it's going to
personalize your experience
i like that you can uh again save time i
like that there's there they're giving
me a plethora if you will of recipes i
like that it's making the cooking
process so easy and so fast and let me
say this to you
i am somebody that actually likes to
cook and i am somebody that actually
does enjoy when i have the time
opening the cookbook finding the recipe
i want to do going to the store buying
all the things but folks
key phrase in that passage there
when i have the time
i don't often have the time and a lot of
people have even less time than i do so
i know how little time i have i can only
imagine how little time some of you have
this is the great thing about hellofresh
is that when i'm using this kit as
somebody who does like to cook i don't
feel like i cheated or shortcut
something i in fact feel like i made a
quality meal from start to finish in a
miraculous amount of time and also i'm
learning from the kids themselves i'm
cooking things and finding recipes that
i might not have ever found or
discovered on my own so here's the thing
go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and use
codetastbuds16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts
taste
hellofresh.com
one six you're gonna use the code
tastebuds16 and you're gonna get six up
to 16 free meals plus three free gifts
it's highly
again hellofresh.com
tastebuds one six use code taste buds
one six get up to 16 free meals plus
three free gifts
uh hey everybody thanks for watching
taste buds uh do us a favor and
subscribe on uh the no press channel
follow us on spotify leave a comment on
itunes that's a huge way that you could
help us that cost you no money if you
want to help the podcast and you love it
merch is available for taste buds on our
website you go to salvocanocomedy.com
for mine
joe's joedorosainfo.com tour dates this
weekend i will be in rochester and
syracuse june 10th and june 11th come on
down that's coming up right now uh the
following weekend south bend indiana
june 16th milwaukee june 17th
minneapolis june 18th weekend after that
you got a hampton beach casino ballroom
june 24th and foxwoods in connecticut
june 25th that's two shows that night
and just looking ahead we got vegas on
july 15th first time headlining vegas at
the virgin hotel theater and then we got
phoenix boulder portland seattle and
vancouver rounding out july
salvocanocomedy.com uh love to see on
the road and i love you i love your
family i love your parents even if they
maybe you're not close to your parents
but i love them
because uh all we need is love right now
uh rolling stones i remember i told
sebastian once i go it was like right
before he got like very famous he was
like he was like
he was like teetering on it yeah it was
about to happen and i saw at the comedy
store
and as i was saying it i was like [ __ ]
like i was like i should have said that
like i feel like that would sound like
an insult
because i go hey go dude
yeah
i go you're my i go you're my mom's
favorite comedian
and and i and it came out of my mouth
and i was like oh i should have said
that and then he went like this he went
like
oh cool and he goes i got the moms yeah
and he was like he was like excited
about it yeah and i was like oh thank
god i thought he was going to be like
insulted if you get the moms i mean the
kids go because you want to take your
mom out to something yeah yeah it's a
it's a big audience i told that to ray
ramona to sorry the only other guy i
ever said that too i was like you're my
mom's favorite
that i see and then i i felt i or when
or everybody loves raymond was her
favorite joke she's it's so good and he
was like and he you know he was like oh
that's great you know like but i was
like that made a little more sense um
but but but those guys are for you know
what i mean like i feel like it's not
insulting what if he goes he goes that's
cool he goes uh are you a fan you're
like no come on dude i'll watch comedy
come on now
he's like my mom does my mom who's
barely in the comedy watching you're a
giant fan
what do you think yeah i'm gonna watch
your sitcom yeah you're right you don't
want him
come on ray you're gonna embarrass
yourself over here right
you're my mom's favorite uh favorite
favorite tv actor that became a comedian
after that
yeah
i i did something right i used to go to
the comedy cellar in 92
four
and uh are you 50 you're 75 years old
yeah so dude when he said his parents
have been a 55 and older community
almost blew my sack off because i'm i am
nine years away from being allowed in
that yeah
nine years away wow you know what you're
saying i'm gonna be 46 43 yeah so yeah
we're knocking on that yeah imagine the
day i could do it dude i would live in
an old person's home in a heartbeat i
think it seems so awesome and you're
with your people packaged you get they
get your food you don't worry about it
when you're talking to people nursing
home i mean i would want a little bit
nicer
no you're not talking about that wow
you could talk me into no no my parents
leave
my parents live in a suburb in jersey
where the qualification to live in that
suburb to buy a house in that suburb
it's white and 55 55 whatever yeah uh 55
and older like so like i would not be
able to buy a house there yeah yeah yeah
but i know what you're talking about
you're talking about like a sort of an
assisted living or or an elder
apartment building those shits are on
youtube
yeah but i'm saying yes some are bad
people yeah some are i mean yeah the
ones that you got a good one like i
understand like if i'm 75 and my
daughter's like we're going to put you
in somewhere i'm going to be like i mean
everybody's my age yeah and then you're
like we're probably playing xbox and
stuff you know it's like you're just
like oh great people are old
are going to list like play video again
like the nursing home is going to be
different like in like we could be in a
nursing home in like 40 years from now
and you could hear like
literally to hear like
snoop dogg and we could be playing and
we were literally playing halo it is no
it's uh it's 100 true it's wild because
i like a lot of uh i like a lot of milf
porn
and you know like like an older woman
it's funny man nine times out of ten now
when i'm watching it they have like cool
tattoos now and i'm like holy [ __ ] man
because this is like
chicks like i mean your 50s now like
it's like that's that you know what i
mean like they were alive like during a
cool time it's not like i don't know if
you like milf porn it seems like you
like cougar mature i should say yeah
mature but you know you can't type in
mature i type it in you type immature
yeah the results come back varied
i could peruse mature means a lot of
different things to a lot of people
you're talking mature you're getting a
blue hair back yeah listen and now you
got and then what do you do do you
peruse i peruse a thumbnail
let me know right now have you hit
mature and spend any time on adult
seniors
what do you well i'm not ageist first of
all
it's true just asking you though do you
type in how mature do you like i mean
raquel welch is in her 70s i'd go out on
a date with her right now if i could yes
but that's a little bit different what
you did there yeah right i'm talking
about when you're typing mature in your
search you tell me you want to go out
with sarandan right now you're telling
me you wouldn't take outside christy
christie brinklin christian
i agree with you i agree susan saran 72
i think she is i i i agree with you i
agree with you there i'm just saying in
the search engine though when you type
it in are you going to go watch
something that seems like
depressing like that like that you want
someone that's like you type in voted
for jimmy carter like you want that age
like you're like i want someone that's
like you know saw some stuff you know
they knew about kennedy you know they
remember kennedy getting shot like
that's what i was where were you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no i type mature and then whatever i'm
attracted to i go for
that's the only way i know i would have
known you know i mean i'm not looking up
like
i i don't google like hip replacement
porn right but that might come up with a
mature no no what are you nuts i don't
know dude i feel like if you type in
mature you're gonna get
older folks you know what god bless the
older folk god bless you
for some reason we we toss them aside
like they're not human beings with needs
you know uh but
someone that sets her leg on the side of
the bed and then yeah yeah
yeah there's some dentures in the cup on
something
yeah no no no no no maybe i don't know
to be honest
daylight in the video
it's it's the clock always says 5 p.m
they just said something that i just
realized every porno movie i've ever
seen is in the daytime
porno who are you
have you ever seen a porn that looks
like it takes place at night i can't
even remember when i've seen one of
those you mean indoors at night or
outdoors at night
it always looks dead well it's lit but
but most porn when you watch it it's a
guy and a chick like in a california
style apartment there's sunlight coming
through those windows well natural light
is going to be nice for the for the for
the low budge for the film
we're dabbling in 8k right now natural
light forget it but i mean it isn't that
interesting
no no because
i mean why would you why would you plus
by the way i've seen plenty of porn at
night
i ca i gotta tell you i said now that
i'm thinking about i think 99 percent of
the porn i have ever seen takes place
during the day
the scenes take place during the day
yeah they got work but your point is
like 9 30 a.m yeah
i'm saying
7 a.m she's here cracking her neck yeah
7 a.m
earlier we've been up for five hours i'm
saying of all ages here yeah i'm saying
of all ages
right
now
just not resonating yeah maybe
let's get the fans in the comments to to
weigh in on this yeah is this bombing
you guys are dead no no not at all okay
all right i'm getting self-conscious
yeah i feel like i crossed some sort of
christian line with nate i don't know
what he's into or what he's not no i
mean it's clean
yeah i'm fine with this talk it's clean
i made my jokes you know i did my thing
could you do a joke about that here
uh about that no
you all like y'all like nighttime porn
yeah what's up
what's up with the non-nighttime porn
yeah no i would that would i would
even say like you know we're watching an
adult film but even if the topic is not
could you even like reference something
like that or boom you lose a lot i'm not
in a i can do whatever i want uh
but
but in your own set of in your own
parameters that you i would
but my mind doesn't go there for like
when i was when you start clean you're
just mine i've never had a sex joke
uh i just my mind just doesn't mean
either so here's the weird thing with me
i don't talk about sex i don't talk
about anything graphic i don't curse
gratuitously i don't really talk about
anything explicit
but i have a well you know i'll have a
well-placed curse here and there if you
know if or if i'm just if i'm not paying
attention i'll curse so i like border on
like clean but not
so i i'm wondering like
like if all i need to do is just kind of
like it's just her so we just shot mike
vaccion special correct right becky
ellen was basically that same way where
he's uh you know it's like he's really
not that dirty yeah and it's just like
some cursing and when i told him i said
just if you can take the cursing out and
not i it's like you know even his
political jokes are very like just funny
political like they're no sides or he's
just trying to be funny and fun and uh
so we did bikes all he did was take out
the curse i mean he can talk about
anything anybody people that want clean
stuff you can talk about whatever
everybody's adults it's like you know i
think people forget how graphic comics
are getting and it's getting so it's
like duck stand hope and then you just
see bad versions of that everywhere
where it's like they're going so far
that it's like all right dude what are
you even talking about now that's the
thing that's always been my not issue
but my thing has been i'm i'm not dirty
but it's dark
but dark can be okay yeah like it's
that's that's always been the thing that
kept me off yeah but the dark can be
okay i mean depends on what the darkness
is but you would you dark it could be
okay it's like i always if you take out
cursing i mean you no one like realizes
it it's like almost like that highlights
the thing
and then so dark can you don't you know
i mean it doesn't be too heavy i i get
uh
but i don't know you know look at louis
ck louis c.k is
a lot of us you could argue huh look at
him do what's that his life yeah but let
me say stand up some of it like there's
a lot of parts you're like it's not
really that dirty there's crazy parts
that are dirty but like louie's like not
it's overall it's simple yeah he'll have
every one of those eleven awesome possum
joke right right but i relate i he's
he's one of the guys i i i always like
looked up to because of that like
because i was always like it's not look
up to him doing what
it's not dirty it's just like you know
like when he'll talk we'll do the thing
about the lady
in the uh in the in the store where she
makes the knickknacks you know what i
mean and like it's sort of
there's nothing
dark about that observation but it sort
of circles back to suicide you know what
i mean like or whatever that's that's
kind of
that but then there's guys there's guys
like like we were talking about ray
romano like ray romano is very clean but
he will drop a [ __ ] once again
so sebastian the same thing yeah yeah
sebastian yes that's where i'm at so i'm
i always wonder i always question should
i just
eliminate it i think it's i sometimes i
think it's good to commit but you you
just don't want to be labeled something
so like me being clean is like it's what
i do but i like i don't you know most
people don't know i'm clean or they they
do now more than they ever did but at
the beginning that's why me coming here
to new york and learning how to do
comedy was
so good because it's like i got to do
all the we did all these
uncensored shows and whatever and i
don't have any of those what was it like
for you getting up in the
bookended by comics that were you know
gratuitously cursing or dirty and you'd
get up and like you know sometimes you
get a crowd that they're they're looking
for something specific that ever that
ever like
was it challenging sometimes or is it
just uh i don't remember it i mean
i i i would have trouble matching
someone's energy i would have more hard
i would have a tougher time with that
than i would or like if the energy's all
high and stuff and then i'm just doing
this and i had to learn how to get
people into my energy really fast but i
mean people don't know dude they're not
sitting there going like ah that wasn't
clean i'm leaving you want to be like no
one thinks of burr as a dirty comic
don't think david tell you don't really
think of a dirty comic
he's a comic and so you just want to
whatever you are just ride the line that
you're not pushed into this category
dad yeah that's smart i agree with that
yeah yeah all right you ever think of
picking up an instrument on stage
that'll paint me into a corner uh
i was gonna do
do something with me do not no no no
guitar no piano how about like a like a
flute
like a well you did the first flute
it would work i do regret um
i do regret i have one great regret in
comedy
how dare you how dare you
you don't even know what we're putting
together right now i can't wait
you know about his you know about his
his
band his hip-hop group
him and this guy oh it's just you never
not really not one listen huh wow no we
listen to him live on the pod okay all
right he's got a he's got music online
right now ten songs at least onto the
moniker salsa windfall yeah yeah but
continue i've seen i mean i saw it a
long time ago no no that was comedy that
was rap i used to do a comedy rap thing
too yeah
white boys in the hood
we did a sex i had a sex crap thing it
was sex wraps
wait that was your biggest regret you
said no that was not a regret is that
when you're doing comedy yeah so that
would be the whole act or you just like
that was a [ __ ] it's the thing i did
with my buddy that was a sigh it wasn't
part of myself you did he did his he did
a set
and did that
on this tv show yeah he's talking about
called white boys in the hood i did a
stand-up set and then they also had my
sex rap group perform which is the best
part of that whole night because i was
there
uh cause it's like he was on it jay was
on it and then we're all hanging out
talent hosted it and talent kept telling
rocco and mike beckham that he's going
to get him on
he goes i think i'm going to get you
guys on and it's a taping i mean there's
contracts you can't just yeah yeah you
can't just throw someone up and so the
whole night was just talent going to
like vecchio and he's like just staying
right there he goes you're probably be
you're probably gonna be next and you're
like and then and showtime's like yo
dude you can't just put people on a tv
tape like you that [ __ ] and he goes ah
he goes don't don't worry about dude
mike mike and rocco just had to sit
there all night and they're like i might
be on tv and i might not that show was a
train wreck
i mean not because of talent just
because of the way it was all right do
you remember the rap
no i actually i really don't um
it bombed really bad it got cut from the
show and then i got into a fight with
the producers and they cut my stand up
set too
uh
doesn't matter
and then but then my passage that's my
derozan
outcome yeah i wasn't on white boys
that might have saved you right now
because we could dig that up yeah
no i was gonna say my greatest my one
great regret in stand-up was that folks
it's summer summer is the season and the
season is sometimes the reason
for not feeling so great
you know a lot of people associate
summer with good feelings rays of
sunshine summer vibes beach vibes beach
body
there's a triggering phrase beach body
that's one that gets me down in the
summertime you know it's sometimes easy
to feel down in the summertime why maybe
you don't feel up to going outside in
the sunlight maybe you don't feel like
you got into the shape you wanted to get
into in the winter maybe you feel
overwhelmed by the options and
possibilities that that social life can
bring into the summer season versus the
winter time that's a little more low-key
a little less busy
look these are things that have set me
off at times during the summer and
that's why i want to talk to you about
better help
just because the season changes doesn't
mean it's a time for you not to be
cognizant of where you're at mentally or
for you to ignore that you might not be
feeling where you want to feel mentally
you know that's the other thing we can
do sometimes when it's bright and sunny
outside we can just say everything's
fine i'll deal with it later
no you need to tend to yourself it's
important up here is just as important
as out here always remember that i love
better help i love what they're offering
i love the ease they're bringing to
finding this help you need i love the
convenience they bring to it i love that
they're offering all kinds of session
types you can do it via phone you can do
it
over the internet i love that
you don't have to do in-person
interviews i love that it's affordable i
love that it's convenient and they're
getting you quickly and i mean quickly
folks
to to to being connected from the minute
you start the process to the to the
point where you're going to be speaking
and connected with somebody that can
help you a therapist that's best for you
this is all done expedited quickly and
that's so key i've said it before and
i'll say it again the bureaucratic
nonsense in the health field is what
often prevents people from getting the
help they need better help us cut that
all out it is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to again that's one of my
favorite aspects of this it is much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
i'm just reiterating all the great stuff
here our listeners get 10 off the first
month at betterhelp.com taste buds it's
better h-e-l-p dot com slash taste buds
folks you're gonna notice a theme in
today's ad takes ad reads it's
summertime summertime can be a thing of
beauty it can also be a thing that's a
bit haunting
uh it can bring up some stuff that you
don't maybe necessarily want to deal
with one of those things for me is diet
often uh summer hits and i say i never
really got around to doing that dieting
i want to do back there in the winter
time that i said i was going to do
so i want to talk to you about noom
uh as somebody that has struggled with
finding the right type of diet
nutritionally uh portion wise all these
things somebody who has used eating as a
scapegoat
and emotionally eaten at times uh in you
know whatever you know
off
state of mind i might have been in
uh
diet is is is crucially connected to not
just your body but also your mindset and
that's what noom is mastering in in in
their approach to helping you understand
a better way of eating
through a better way of understanding
yourself
this is not a restrictive diet or
workout program nume is using psychology
to empower you
with practical knowledge and a skill set
so you can build a better a a healthier
most importantly a more sustainable
type of eating habit and and eating
behavior and dietary habits and dietary
behaviors uh the psychology approach is
based on scientifically proven
principles they use for one cbt which is
cognitive behavioral therapy i'm a big
fan of this i've actually done this
therapy in actual therapy before and i
think it's great and i think it's a
wonderful
thing that they're this is one of the
therapies specifically that they're
connecting to lifestyle and diet because
that type of therapy is based completely
in triggering events why do i eat some
of the things i do why do i indulge in
certain ways well if you kind of
backpedal and follow the steps backwards
oh it's this and when this happens it
sets me off and then i want to do this
and the next thing you know you're a
whole pizza down so
i i like that they understand that the
weight loss journey is difficult and
that it's filled with ups and downs
uh but they they know and understand and
believe that it's about progress okay
and i'm telling you it is about progress
and everybody's journey is different
okay it's not about restricting it's not
about what you can or can't it's about
having the knowledge and wisdom you need
to make informed choices it's that
simple okay so what i want you to do
you're going to sign up for a free trial
to get psychology based support and
motivation to reach your goals at
n-o-o-m-com
slash taste bud singular n-o-o-m-com
taste bud that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash taste bud to sign up for
your free trial i wasn't on white boys
that might have saved you right now
because we could dig that up yeah
no i was going to say my greatest my one
great regret in stand up was that
because i because i played music early
on
and because i was into writing and
theater and writing sketches and short
plays and all those things
when i first started doing stand-up i
incorporated that sort of stuff much
much more into the comedy and as i moved
along in comedy and started to learn how
to hone in on one thing all of it went
away
and i i i i
i you know it's funny like i was
watching like sandra bernhardt the other
night and i was like
man see she pulled all that in man she
like does a song and then she does stand
up and then that and i'm like where's
she been i wish i could she's still out
there doing like one woman shows she
still has a big following would you take
her on a night on the town
i'm not attracted to her okay i'm not
that she'd be attracted to me either
right but my point is is like i always
think i i envy those guys like demetri
martin was one of those guys like when
he did his special there were all these
like elements to it that i thought was
really really new york beat that out of
you so new york at the beginning was
like you couldn't do anything else
outside of stand up he was like this is
what we do you do jokes i always would
only describe new york is like new
york's like your dad that's like just be
funny do the work and then la's your
like crazy aunt that's like no go chase
yeah go write a song and you need both
of those things right you need to learn
how to do a joke but you also need to go
and like remember podcasts first started
i mean we're like
we would all say like i'm gonna do a
podcast at like what uh what are you
you're gonna do a podcast
now everybody's doing them you can't but
like you can't not have them but back
then i mean it was like if you even
thought of doing it it's like what do
you lose like do you know yeah how much
of a loser you are starting a podcast i
remember the first script i ever wrote
was with burr we tried to write this
movie about stand-up and
nothing ever happened with it but like i
remember he said to me don't bring this
up at the seller yeah because he goes
we're gonna get trashed for no good
reason yeah and one night we actually
finally just said [ __ ] it and they were
like whoever was at the table that
lineup of
yeah
you missed that of meanest yeah i
actually really doesn't exist anymore no
100 i mean 100 i haven't been back so
it's like this is heard yeah it was
patrice keith apollo i mean it was you
know but uh i remember we got up to
leave and i think it was keith he goes
keith goes where are you going stupid
and we go we're going to work on our
script he goes
exactly what you just did yeah you know
work on your script and bill was like
yeah keith we're going to try to better
our careers
and then we just left but i was like my
god you have to justify
everything but that's why i didn't play
music i remember telling burr i want to
play music
and he was like he was like just be
ready because it's going to be
because of this scene and i always
wished i had spent a little more time in
the brooklyn rooms but at the same time
i didn't i couldn't afford to do that i
had to make a living you know a lot of
those guys in brooklyn like their
parents they had cash you know what i
mean they couldn't they had time to
experiment like i feel like we were all
in this position of like hey man let's
do or die dude oh we had
i think the better i think you you need
to have that the better comics that's
why comics come out of new york they're
better because you do need that like yo
dude just do the jokes it's about the
jokes i remember telling to tell
well after a late i did a late night set
one of the first ones i did and then i
was like i gotta come up with another
one a new set he's like oh do ya
because that's what we do
he's writing jokes hard and you're like
oh yeah i'm sorry you know but like you
want some sympathy and then it's just
like nobody cares and that nobody cares
attitude i think makes the best comics
but you only need it so long and then
you do need to go somewhere where if you
go i'm gonna write a script someone's
gonna be like well good for you
right that's great that's the second
hour yeah that's the second half of your
career that you go yeah yeah i agree
well there you go and that's uh we've
eventually found ourselves arguing about
food on a podcast can you imagine
telling that group back there to seller
a radio program will you argue about
bagels
i think they would have been you would
have
chased i think they would be standing
right here booing us the whole time like
it would be
it was i've never seen i was i was
telling karen feehan about it the other
night
and i was like karen you're like you
would have been in all your glory i was
like you have a viciousness like about
you i was like you really missed like a
time like when it was when it was colin
patrice
burr bobby
uh d'apollo
uh
keith probably norton norton
judy gold bobby oh he said
it was so [ __ ] mean
oh my god what was the most what was the
most traumatized
huh was the most traumatized that you
got at that table steve byrne um
yeah
the most traumatized i ever got was uh
kurt metzger drew a picture of me
kurt was really good at caricatures he's
a really good artist actually uh
kurt metzger jay
yeah
yeah
kurt drew a picture of me
but it was like a character so it really
accentuated
all my worst qualities
and i was literally like standing like
hunched over
like this and like i this like pelican
chin and it was so good
and so funny but so hurtful and they
passed it around the entire olive tree
cafe at the seller
and i looked up and the waitresses
across the room were looking at it and
pointing at me and laughing yeah and it
was
i i left yeah i left i was like i was
devastated and steve byrne and bobby
called me the next day and they're like
dude come on we love you come do this
gig with us and then i went did a gig
with steve burn and bobby and then
stephen and bobby got into a fight on
the cake
they weren't they were bringing me to
make me feel better like we're all
friends and then they got into the fight
that was so bad steve got all out of the
car on a bridge and just walked the rest
away back into
steve the night before
so this was two nights after
that happened we opened these [ __ ]
windows yeah all right that this was two
nights after that had happened yeah on
the night in between the two i guess
steve and bobby had did another gig
and bobby picked up steve
and steve had some girl with him because
he was single at the time and he put the
girl in the front seat and he just said
i think he i think he fell asleep and
bobby just had to entertain this girl
[Laughter]
and he was so mad and the whole trip
dude he was going yeah you [ __ ] is that
what you do you put your chick in the
front and he just wouldn't stop
and like steve just finally hit a
[ __ ] wall and he's like you're
[ __ ] miserable man [ __ ] this and he
got out he got out of the car on the
bridge and just walked where did the
girl did the girl stay in the car no
this was the night before bobby didn't
give him [ __ ] about till the next night
we're all together yeah and the next day
we're all together it was supposed to be
at night they were making me feel better
and show that we're all friends deep
down and they and it was so it was
that scene was so [ __ ] insane
like steve i had i was once a boston
comedy club i had a uh i for some reason
i had a carrot top dvd
which is rightfully so you mean that you
mean on your person yeah and i don't
even remember why
and
i'll defend carrot top to this day i
think that guy's one of them
scott thompson yeah yeah yeah he's got
something yeah scott thompson's kids in
the hall yeah i know but i thought it
was also anyway my apologies but he's
great he's great he's the sweetest dude
in the world seems very nice he's a
legend he's someone that you people are
the trash and you're like well who's
doing what he's doing no one's doing
that right so but i have it and so i
don't know steve's an older comic you
know i'm brand new and like he just
comes and looks at it just drops it on
the ground and walks away and but i have
no context to like i don't even know
what world i'm walking into
and i think i see steve in nashville now
i think about that every day did you
ever bring it up to him oh yeah i
brought it up recently do you remember
i've never let it go
but it's very funny uh romy rome you had
to bring this yeah
yeah romy was
this is my this is my favorite seller
memory
this is my favorite seller memory of i
know left short
like
oh [ __ ] all right i'll make it well no i
like this is good this is great
let's hear it and also decide on what
chant you're going to do
are you doing so
[ __ ] they might be good at salty nate
might be good at salty all right
hey look tim dillon's in town folks that
actually
just gonna look like nikki yeah yeah uh
she's cute nikki in case you're watching
yeah
we're not making sure yeah she's very
fun to do right set up three chairs
right there the comics look straight out
of that window open it yeah set up a cam
mica set up a camera across the street
facing this and then anybody who just
walks by we could just roast it i love
it
i love it so much fun
the uh the uh that's great that's great
i love it it's a great idea no it is it
is that's great
sarah silverman will you come
i think we did that we did that at amy
we were at amy schumer's mom's once and
she lives like near the beach and we
were sitting at the boardwalk it was me
bobby amy and keith
and and and kumia and every time
somebody walked by that looked like one
of us we did that but we only did it
with like the ugliest version
and this old man went walking by and
keith chased him down the boardwalk and
was going anthony anthony i want to do
the show
have me on our day the guy like turned
around and knew we were making fun of
him but didn't know why
and uh anyway but my favorite selling
remember romy rome who's the nicest guy
in the world
he was walking around
uh he had skittles
he had a bag of skittles and he was just
walking around table to table
and i was sitting at the bar talking to
steve
and steve's like trying to like he was
it's the same thing like he was like he
was so he was so much older than me at
that time in the game and he was just
giving me like advice i was so new in
town he's trying to give me advice and
all you could hear is romy table table
y'all want some skittles don't want some
skittles y'all what's because he's being
like the nicest guy he's literally he's
a wonderful person yeah yeah and steve's
like sonny derose you got to [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ
and like it just it's getting closer and
and then closer steve just goes
hey hey romy hey romy awesome skittles
man can i have some skittles bro he goes
yeah of course steve gives him the bag
he just goes
it just sounded like marbles all over
the floor and he threw the bag on the
ground just turned around and just kept
giving me advice
some waiter
so much stuff back it was it's so brutal
back then they're all great stories now
but they're back then you're like i mean
the nerves
is unreal i just i kind of just missed
that like when i got into like the last
the last
like year of that or whatever it was
like seven eight years ago whatever it
was and it's yeah and i just i'm lucky i
caught like a little like a tail end of
it but it was it's so it's so
i used to look forward to it lynn
copplets once brought keith
homemade
spaghetti sausage meatballs she made it
from scratch and we were at the boston
comedy club it was when pj landers was
running the boston common club remember
that and keats holding this [ __ ]
tupperware dude filled with homemade
gravy and meatballs and everything
and bobby goes where'd you get that from
and then keith goes lynn coppola's made
it for me bobby goes why and he goes
because she likes me stupid and bobby
goes oh yeah boom just hits it the thing
just
hits the ground it goes [ __ ]
everywhere
keith starts laughing like
hyperventilating laughing at how mean it
is goes and sits on the side bobby's
laughing i'm laughing we sat there and
just watched pj sweep it all off
and pj was like pj could murder you yeah
and he didn't want to yell at keith or
bobby yeah like because because they
were like so established like so he just
he just mopped it all up pj fought jimmy
martinez
did you fight it yeah pj earned his
stripes more than one that day yeah uh
we were all scared i loved jimmy but we
were scared to death
oh yeah yeah and they were they're just
so both big dudes like it's it's uh and
pj you just watched it i don't remember
i just remember hearing about it but it
was but it was like such a it was it was
such like a seem a fair fight like it
was like if those two dudes were
fighting it's two big big dudes
jim martinez used to when every time you
do a show he wouldn't need the
microphone so we'd go the improv and i
was like running it with dustin yeah uh
or the broadway comedy club it was the
improv at the time into that upstairs
room and so jimmy would go on stage and
like get the microphone and just walk it
all the way off to the side of the stage
and then just do his act with no
microphone because he talked loud and
then he'd say good night and i was
hosting and i always had to go get the
microphone i'd be so mad
because i was like i gotta walk over
there like an idiot
and just i gotta gather all your things
because you won't
dude
i saw jimmy once he was on stage at
stamp new york no mike
mike britt walked in
and mike britt was standing so stand up
new york you know how it's set up
there's like the bar
and then there was i don't think the
window's there anymore but there used to
be an opening at the end of the bar was
a service window so if you were on stage
you could see clear into the bar but it
was still a separate room
jimmy was on stage saw mike britt walk
into the bar and he goes oh [ __ ] my man
left the stage
went over and had a four minute
conversation with mike brin at the bar
and then walk back like nothing happened
not to be funny nothing it was literally
just impulsive came over here but he
went and did it yeah he cried
was like what the [ __ ] is going on dude
jimmy's the best dude like he's yeah
jimmy's awesome man awesome like it was
that dude was yeah it was just another
did he like someone what band did he
like loved he was friends with somebody
he loved like the widest pants yeah he
loved like offspring yeah yeah and stuff
like that like he loved he loved like
the whitest like like california poppy
punk yeah yeah
he's awesome i still see i run into
jimmy here and there he's good he's
doing what he's a good guy man i miss
him i miss jimmy too we could uh we
could do this we could do this all damn
day
i know i'm wondering like do we i mean
we got to get to
a battle here it might be a truncated
one at that
um we got till what
we got so why before before you gotta
start like doing your thing yeah what
time is it now it's 116.
so two to three three to four this is
the question i always ask yeah
you usually don't want to do this but
we're rolling do we just split it into a
two-parter and do two parts with nate
and then do another one ourselves
i'm okay with that yeah yeah pimp how do
you feel about that i'm all right
i'm good you don't ask me or mike oh so
i don't think i'm getting asked people
don't get a battle this week they'll be
okay with it will you guys be okay with
it
well we could start the battle and then
do it to be continued because we got a
hell of a battle yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe we end it with the salty do you
want to do the salty
where are we at now
we're at like 45 no like 48. we could do
that because you want to start it and to
be tb did yeah
should be continued tbc yeah yeah let's
do that
all right nate we're going to let you as
guest of honor pick which chant we do
there's two chants there's a love chant
that we do because we we
they've things have gotten heated here
on taste buds mm-hmm
so there was a love change you used to
take home the stress with him yeah or
maybe me too yeah and we would so we
would do we would do a love chant no
matter what happens i love you we have
to say that three times looking into
each other's eyes
and that's what that would set the table
for maybe it's not to be so vicious with
each other yeah because it was getting
really heated when we were like popping
blood vessels right
and then he would call me up and say are
we good
and i'd be like what are you talking
about he's like well yes dave you really
got into it with that strawberry milk
and i would say you don't need to take
that home with you right yeah then he
brought it and it actually worked right
yes i agree it did work but we also felt
it took a little too much of the wind
out of our sails sometimes right
the other chant that we started to do
because we felt we lost some of our edge
although the merch just came out and
there is it's uh no matter what happens
i love you merch right that uh you know
what i mean you like to move units but
okay okay no no no but it's okay it's
time to get salty
three times and as soon as you're done
chanting it we each have to insult each
other and we get how long pimp
a minute a minute 30 seconds 30 seconds
and then yeah he usually bangs some pots
and pans but we know we have to stop
yeah
is that that's the one people want or is
that well i think they like no matter
what happens i love you but uh lately
it's been
how much have you done one versus the
other
we've did no matter what happens i love
you for months and months you've been
doing it sounding good salty for a
couple months maybe yeah
what was the last episode what'd y'all
do it's been salty it's been all salty
lately oh well then let's do the loved
one you got merch you want to sell it
i'd like to see some positivity between
you two yeah okay all right all right
ready yeah
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you all right here
we go time to
b-a-t-t-l-e butts
here we go get destroyed back in the
cellar today
by the way
these are and i love it and the fans
love it but these are all his he brought
all these to the table yeah i never got
one they told me listen we're gonna do
chants yeah yeah that's like all right
by the way you have the reaction the
same reaction of everything yeah yeah
there we go
so we're gonna do this as a three-way
battle each person has their is their
own man uh we have three islands
battling today
nate ice cream
versus sal cookies versus me cake uh-oh
folks what's going to happen on taste
buds will nate win with his ice cream or
will he just melt will sal's cookie
crumble
or will joe get his cake and eat it too
stay tuned for next week's action-packed
taste buds